So let's begin by recalling this thing
called the instance variables. In the case of
Class Movie, there were several of them,
title, storyline, poster image URL, and trailer YouTube
URL. Now, further recall that these variables
are associated with every instance that we create.
For example, both Toy Story and Avatar have
their own copies of these variables. So I
could print out Toy Story's storyline and I could
also print out Avatar's storyline. Sometimes however, we need
variables that we want all of our instances to
share. So consider the variable valid_ratings for a
movie. This is an array or a list, of
all possible ratings a movie could have. Now, it
would not quite make sense to say, hey, here
are Toy Story's valid ratings, and here are Avatar's
valid ratings. They would essentially be the same for
all instances. Thus, this variable is really associated with a
Class Movie. And is therefore called a Class Variable.
Let's see it in action. So here is the code
for our Class Movie. And behind this Python file
is the other Python file we created, where we made
a bunch of movie instances. So I'm going to
begin by making changes to my Class Movie. Now here
I will define a variable called valid ratings. Now notice
that this variable valid ratings is defined at the level
of the class and is outside the init function. In
order to start using this variable, we will begin by
saving this file first. So next I'm going to go
to my other Python file. By the way, this is
the file where we are defining a bunch of movie
instances. And here, I will scroll down all the way
to the bottom. And comment out any sort
of print or output statements. Now, I'm doing
this so I can focus primarily on valid ratings. Now, here, I will try to print
out the value of the variable valid ratings by saying, print, and the name of my
class, which is media.Movie, followed by the name
of the variable, which is valid_ratings. There.
Let me save and run this program. And boom. There
it is. A list of all of my valid ratings.
Notice how we use the class name movie to access
this variable. This means that all instances of this class
movie. Toy Story, Avatar and others, they can share this
list, they can share this list to see if their
individual rating is a valid one or not. Okay, so
the one last thing I want to do is go back
to my class movie. Now notice that the value
of this variable valid_strings is probably a constant, by that
I mean, that the value of this variable is probably
not going change every now and then. When we define
a constant like this, the Google Style Guide for
Python recommends that we use all caps or an upper
case to define a variable like that. I'm going to
go ahead and save this file and then go back
to my other Python file and change the variable name there as well. [NOISE]
Let me save and run this program to see if it still
works. And there it is, I get the correct output one more time.